my name is Matt Walsh I'm here as a
husband father and concerned citizen of
the state of Tennessee and I want to
thank the committee for allowing me to
speak and for all of you on the
committee who support this important
legislation
now I know that we can't agree on very
much these days but we should be able to
agree that our most solemn
responsibility as individuals as a state
and as a country is to protect our
children we should be able to agree that
children do not have the physical
emotional or mental capacity to protect
themselves or to make life-altering
decisions
we should be able to agree that it's
never okay to chemically castrate
sterilized butcher or mutilate a child
and in fact all decent people do agree
on all these points but many of the
people hold power in this country and
who run our institutions including our
medical institutions do not pass this
basic test of decency
they've made House Bill one not only
necessary one of the most important
piece of legislation this body has ever
taken into consideration
in service to a radical far left agenda
children are being led down a path of
gender confusion and identity crisis
this crisis manufactured by the cultures
and exploited and monetized by medical
professionals who first put them on
chemical castration drugs like Lupron
then the victims are given cross-sex
hormones which often have irreversible
and permanent effects
finally before the age of 18 many of
these kids will undergo surgery such as
double mastectomies which will alter
their bodies and their lives forever
taking something away that they can
never get back
no matter how much they regret it in the
future and so many do
this is happening across the country and
that includes in our state
children are being coerced into
decisions that they are not equipped to
make in pursuit of a goal that that can
never be attained the girl who gets the
double mastectomy is no closer to being
a boy after getting the procedure than
she was before she's still a girl and
will always be a girl just now a
mutilated and damaged one
now you may notice that most of the
people who support and advocate for this
Butchery are not petitioning to lower
the drinking age they're not trying to
pass a law to allow middle schoolers to
get tattoos or take out mortgages or
purchase firearms or cigarettes that's
because even they recognize that miners
lack the maturity and discernment
required to make those choices they
recognize it when it comes to alcohol
and tobacco and guns and mortgages and
Tattoos yeah when it comes to
irreversible life-altering medical
interventions suddenly these same people
discover a new found confidence in the
responsible decision-making powers of
children
their position is not even consistent or
coherent much less morally or
scientifically defensible we cannot
allow this wickedness to continue we
cannot tolerate it we are decent and
rational people in this state we love
our children we recognize basic truths
one of those basic truths is that a
child who is confused about her identity
needs guidance and love and clarity
she does not need hormone injections and
scalpels
she needs she needs and deserves to be
protected from those child abusing
quacks and soulless vultures who wish to
exploit her confusion for their own gain
that's why we need this law our kids
cannot protect themselves but we can and
we must and we are thank you we've heard
in the news last week
and even today that
it's pro-life to vote against this bill
we've heard that um
suicides are prevalent
and suicide has impacted my family so
I'm sensitive when I hear something like
that
I I I've read some of the stuff that
you've done and I was wondering can you
speak to the statistics
of of
Mental Health
and Suicidal Tendencies
for the people who have gone through
transition for people who have not in
your studies from what I've read can you
can you speak to that Mr you recognize
sure well the claim that uh you know
doing the chemical castration drugs or
surgery or hormonal intervention the
claim that this prevents suicide or has
a positive psychological effects down
the line is utterly totally baseless
there are no credible long-term studies
that bear that out and one of the
reasons for that is that there couldn't
possibly be any credible long-term
studies because we've never done this to
kids on this scale ever before in
history so this current uh shall we say
crop of children they are the guinea
pigs this is this is all experimental
we're sort of trying it out on them to
see if it works now they have attempted
a few times to do studies and the
interesting thing is that the world
Professional Association of transgender
Health wpath which is a radical far left
pro-trans organization they commissioned
a study to try to prove that um that
hormones and puberty blockers a
decreased suicide rates among
trans-identified Youth and even in their
own study they found that they couldn't
they couldn't they couldn't prove it
they couldn't make that link because
it's just not possible to do the other
thing I've mention too is that
you know the the
number of trans identified youth has
skyrocketed in recent years we're
talking about exponential 10x 20x growth
just huge numbers having of a have
increased and what we hear from the
pro-trans side is that well this is not
a social contagion it's just that you
know there's always been this many trans
people it's just that they were not in
an affirming
uh environment before in history and so
they couldn't come out and now for the
first time trans people have have the
ability to live their truth so to speak
well if that's the case and there have
always been these sort of like millions
of trans people and if it's also true
that if we don't affirm them that it
would cause them to commit suicide then
we should be able to look back in
history and find just this unbroken
incredible epidemic of children
mysteriously killing themselves because
they weren't being affirmed as trans and
what you find is that that didn't exist
I mean the the youth suicide rate has
increased exponentially alongside trans
affirmation so trans affirmation causes
the suicide rate not the other way
around the last thing I'll note is that
um
the suicide rate among trans identified
people is is Sky High it remains Sky
High all the data shows us it remains
Sky High even after surgery and in fact
in the most reliable day that we have
it's a years after surgery when
suicidality is the highest for
trans-identified people that's the
reality
professing you good okay any further
questions for Mr Walsh while we are out
of session uh Mr Hammer Mr
representative Hammer thank you
um thank you Mr Walsh I found it
interesting one of our uh
people testified today that they uh had
their gender affirming surgery at 16. I
know uh you and former comments
mentioned this on your blog at about 16
you're an adult who's mature and can
make decisions uh you're that at 16. I
don't care what anybody says even going
so far as to say you know 16 people when
you're 16 you should be married and uh
and could be pregnant or should be
pregnant so I'm curious if 16 is uh a uh
an adult in your view why is this bill
have the minor defined as 18.
yeah that's that's a hit piece you took
from Media Matters uh from something
when I was a radio host uh 13 14 years
ago in my early 20s uh it's also not an
accurate reflection of what I actually
said
um I was talking about
uh the fact that people tended to marry
young historically and that's all that
that was about
um
how does that relate to this
subject
just curious your definition of if you
feel like people are adults at 16 should
people are adults at 18. but actually
they're your your brain is not fully
developed until you're 25.
so we should be having a conversation
about whether we should even be doing
these surgeries to people at 18. but
certainly before 18 it's it's absurd
I mean do you do you think that a 16
year old can meaningfully consent to
having their body parts removed
do you
no
we do not yeah we ask the questions it's
not it's
got uh representative Hammer you are
recognized
no more questions okay uh representative
Clemens you recognized
yeah thank you Mr chairman
um can you give us a summary of your
educational background or your health
care education and experience Mr Walsh
you recognized my experience in
healthcare your educational background
I'm just curious you you testified as to
a lot of your own research so I'm
curious for what purpose you do that and
what background you have to qualifies
you to speak to them well my background
that qualifies me to speak to this is
that I'm a human being with a brain and
common sense and I have a soul
and so therefore I think it's a really
bad idea it's a chemically castrate
children that is my experience
um also I I did now it's true I didn't I
didn't go to college but I did go to
school long enough to learn how to read
so I can read the data for myself and
that's exactly what I've done
representative Clements and for what
purpose do you um conduct your research
and use this brain of yours Mr Walsh
you're recognized
I use it for the purpose of trying to
protect children from being castrated
and mutilated that's one of the things I
try to do
thank you Mr chairman you don't use it
to get clicks on your State application
well using it right now to try to get
clicks with this interaction
on no I I I I I I really like the idea
of getting uh of drawing attention to
the fact that this is happening to
children I know you seem to find it very
amusing I don't
representative Clements
well you made a lot of
misrepresentations and and category
characterizations in your comments I
think it's fair for me to question your
background
let me finish please
you're recognized representative
Clements
you know if you're going to come before
a committee and make
mischaracterizations and
misrepresentations it's a fair game for
us to ask you your educational
background and your foundational
knowledge for making such
characterizations that's that's my point
so I'm curious about you speaking to the
development of the human brain at by the
age of 25 I seem to recall you
advocating on behalf of firearm
possession at the age of 18. do you
think that's what's let's stay on the
bill please
that's all I got okay yeah well uh can I
respond to that
representative Mitchell you'll recognize
I can't respond to them thank you Mr
chairman so
you know you I think your original
article blog post or tweet or whatever
kind of started this Firestorm so I'm
trying to figure out you know where we
need to look for these surgeries because
I'm still trying to find you know the
surgeries because you know the the
sponge of the bill last week I kind of
agreed with him I said we need to split
this bill in the two parts you know I
may agree with him on the surgery part
because I don't think it's happening so
you know you seem to have started this
so I need your evidence of where these
surgeries are occurring in Tennessee
could you could you give me you know
places times maybe some names uh or
something that you know you know of yeah
I watch Mr Walsh you're recognized
my evidence is the health care
provider's own words you know I I uh I
outlined Vanderbilt health and their
transgender Care Program
and the people that work for that
program their own words talking about
what they do and talking about for
example providing the chemical
castration drugs to to adolescent
children as far as surgeries you know
double mastectomies do happen and the
way that I know that they happen is that
after I called attention to this program
at Vanderbilt they said that they were
going to stop performing they were going
to put a pause on the program that
performs these surgeries on minors and
so if you're pausing the program to
perform surgeries on minors then I'm
going to assume
that the program existed otherwise you
couldn't have paused it so now the exact
number of kids who are being subjected
to this I don't know exactly it's really
hard to come up with those numbers I
think because the people doing it aren't
really proud of it and there's not a lot
of interest on their end to tell us but
I do think that you know even one child
being horrifically mutilated is too many
so I know that it's more than one and
that's reason enough to put a stop to
this I would say
representative Mitchell you reckon yeah
so
so last week I had an amendment that you
know we're looking to protect children
from abuse and I also had an amendment
to stop cosmetic surgery of rhinoplasty
and breast enhancements to minors how
would you feel about that
you know is that mutilation of children
as well under the age of 18 things
representative Mitchell that's not on
the bill that we have
it is it's surgical it's surgical I I'm
happy to
answer that
you're free to answer Mr walls okay uh
my personal feeling about banning breast
enhancements for for minors
yes I would be all four personally I'd
be all four Banning that absolutely yeah
representative Mitchell okay and and so
I think the previous representative you
know proved that you have no medical
background correct
uh no so so you're here probably just as
a public policy you you're trying to
address good public policy correct or Mr
Walsh yes so
I just have to question you know some of
your public policy you know expertise
when you know I'm reading here Singapore
is able to have nice things in part
because they execute drug dealers by
hanging and arrest even Petty vandals
and thieves and beat them with a cane
until they bleed we don't have nice
things here because we aren't willing to
do what is required to maintain them so
you know with statements like that I
kind of have to question your public
policy beliefs and you know and you also
stated there had been no studies well
I'm sitting here holding a study from
the American Academy of Pediatrics from
the University of Pittsburgh about the
uh suicidal disparities between
transgender and cisgender adults and
children so
I think you know before you state things
you may need to know all the facts
thank you all right thank you is that
Congressman uh chairman Williams you
recognize
thank you Mr chairman I make motion go
back out of session or back into session
thank you is there an objection
all right there is
that there's
would you withdraw
but
um yes I will withdraw okay
is there any further questions for Mr
Walsh
okay see none uh thank you for your
testimony thank you okay uh okay
representative Clements would you like
to call up
uh yes Mr chairman thank you I'm I just
have a single question for I think